so back with us hector garza national
border patrol council
hector what do you make of this i
i it does seem to be a big 180 in the
part of the administration i'm sure you
would welcome it regardless what do you
think
well we're always going to be supporting
a border wall
along the border in order to secure the
the united states right uh but
unfortunately this type of uh board wall
that's being built in yuma arizona does
pretty much nothing to be able to uh
provide border security what the
administration is trying to accomplish
here is that they're trying to reroute
every single asylum seeker illegal alien
that comes across a border through a
specific crossing point because what the
by the administration has created is an
actual unofficial portal entry so that
border patrol agents can process illegal
aliens
you know that we have a a legal port of
entry where where uh people seek entry
to the united states but this
administration has now created uh
unofficial ports of entry uh between
ports of entry where we can now process
these illegal aliens and unfortunately
this is just part of the plan and this
section of the wall unfortunately does
uh very little to secure the border
you know after um and you know that's
far better than i but uh i i i kind of
sense from the administration they don't
like the whole concept of a wall um that
it's you know
it's ugly they don't like the notion
behind it that you're trying to keep
people out
yet walls do work uh where we're having
migrant surges or in areas where there
are no walls
and i'm just wondering
why
go through hoops debating what clearly
seems to work no matter whether you
consider it an eyesore or not
well we do know that there's been a lot
of political conversations regarding uh
senator markelly and senator mark kelly
pushing for this uh section of the
border wall in arizona uh we do believe
that there is a some political uh
agenda behind this part of the wall in
order to seek some type of support for
senator markelly uh but that's something
that uh that usually happens with these
border issues um we would call for it
for border walls along the laredo sector
right along the laredo sector has zero
miles of border wall zero infrastructure
and the problem you know is that we
didn't get a border wall in certain
parts of the border but we also didn't
get any technology and if you remember
the uh a lot of the democrats and the
body administration they promised us
that they would be building a virtual
wall and that has not happened in the
almost two years of the administration
uh and unfortunately uh the border
patrol agents and the and the citizens
uh that live along the border
communities are are left holding the bag
with with all these problems that are
created uh with these border security
policies
hector i haven't had a chance to talk to
you since the homeland security
secretary announced that the border is
secure
what did you think of that
that's a flatter lie to the american
public we we see it every single day
where the border is definitely not
secured and not only are we seeing um
an uncontrollable amount of of
asylum seekers that are allegedly
seeking asylum uh but we're seeing uh uh
untold uh thousands and thousands of
pounds of illegal narcotics that are
coming across the border we're also
seeing so many criminal illegal aliens
that are getting away uh uh when they
cross the border illegally so it's tough
to to to believe what's coming out of
this administration's mouth when they
say that the board is secure when we
along the border seeing the disasters
are being created due to an unsecured
border we're seeing daily
deaths with illegal aliens involved in
uh in human smuggling events we're
seeing police pursuits along the uh
along the southern border on a daily
basis several times a day so for this
administration to come out and say that
the board is secure that's just a flat
out lie to the american public we would
welcome them to come to the board to
talk to the real board of security
professionals and see what's actually
happening down on the border
why don't you think they do
well unfortunately it's all political uh
these politicians the democrats obama
administration they've put politics
ahead of the safety and security
american public uh they're just trying
to uh secure their elections we know
we've got the midterms and then before
you know it we're gonna have president
trump running again uh against these uh
against these uh these democrats uh but
it's all about politics and
unfortunately they are forgetting about
the safety and security of the american
public they're forgetting about us on
the border the border communities are
being ravaged by by human and drug
smuggling incidents and and and and and
criminal organizations are taking over
our communities and unfortunately our
children our families our neighbors and
people are actually dying because of
this crisis
but a lot of these towns and cities
north of texas don't think too keenly
when when the governor governor abbott
uh sends those same migrants and those
trying to cross into the country into
their neck of the woods then it's a very
different crisis isn't it
well what what's important is that is
that governor abbott and uh and governor
ducey from arizona they continue sending
these illegal immigrants to washington
dc new york so they actually know how
how these illegal aliens are taking up
the local resources from the communities
that are meant for the for the for the
people of those towns and those in those
communities um that we know that uh
governor abbott has been doing an
amazing job in proving a point that
illegal immigration that's out of
control actually creates problems in
communities and and it takes services
away from the people that are paying for
those services uh which is a taxpayer uh
and unfortunately these are illegal
agents that do ravage these communities
do take a lot of these health care uh
resources education resources and
unfortunately many of these illegal
agents are even victimized themselves
because uh what the bad administration
does is we send these illegal aliens to
these communities and these illegal aids
are then victimized by the cartels that
control these communities uh in the
united states so this is just a big
problem overall and and unfortunately
these the policies of the body
administration is affecting real people
like us uh in laredo texas and real
people in in northern states uh in the
united states and and and quite frankly
he needs to stop and the administration
needs to put the safety secure the
american public ahead of their political
agenda
hector thank you very good catching up
with you hector garza i just i'm steve
ducey i'm brian killme and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis